[Music]
today reviewing the Intel Arc b570
battle mage GPU following up to b580 the
price for this is supposed to be $220 us
the b580 launched at$ 250 for the
Baseline pricing and that means that the
b570 is actually one of the cheapest new
generation cards that we've reviewed in
years at this point so close competition
uh includes the 4060 sort of 300 bucks
or so and the 7600 at around 250 plus or
minus a bit the the 6600 and the 6600 XT
really are the most similar in price at
least at one point uh to where this is
today now this review is a little
interesting because battle mage overall
had a pretty good launch it was well
received by and large uh it had a couple
caveats just like the alus je used in
the first generation of Intel Arc but
battl Mage more recently the story has
been around but what happens if you pair
a b580 with a lower end CPU so we went
through and we added the 12400 and the
5600x at fixed clocks uh for another
round of tests in addition to our 9800
x2d platform we ran several cards
through it the short answer to the
question of whether it changes the
performance in a way that reflects in
our particular approach to reviews is no
it does not there's one scenario where
it really shows up uh we'll talk about
that but for the most part there's not
really any change and so we'll we'll
talk through why that is and where the
overhead exists it does exist it's a
real thing uh it just doesn't
materialize in the way we test but uh
that makes this pretty interesting
there's there's a lot of charts it's uh
it's like doing all the work three times
uh but we were able to do it where
there's only two times the amount of
charts great before that this video is
brought to you by the anex C8 cases we
reviewed the antec C8 argb a few months
ago and found it to be an overall
competitive performer using unique 160
mm fans there's also a version without
included fans and it's competitively
priced while still offering attention to
detail key elements like the airflow
partition for better directing air
intake it also has high quality kill
management grommets and limited
obstructions for bottom air intake the
argb variant includes all these features
but also 260 mil reverse blade fans and
one 140 mm fan learn more at the link in
the description below all right so I am
actually really excited about this
because uh doing bottleneck tting is
always really fun it is cool to see how
Stuff performs on high end or low end
versus what you normally do so we'll
talk more about that but we'll link our
b580 review if you want more detail on
frame time pacing that discussions in
that video and on the basics of the
architecture there's a few unique frame
time pacing issues with battle mage
those persist on b570 when they're
present uh but they have done a good job
at getting rid of the really really
common ones that were present in the a
series a770 a750 so Intel's on an
improvement Arc not intentional uh but
they do still have some hurdles to
tackle all right so for a quick recap of
the specs the b580 GPU is a 20x core
configuration on five render slices it
has a 190 W claimed tbp or total board
power 12 GB of gddr6 memory bandwidth is
relatively high for a card of this class
456 GB per second the b570 car drops two
of the XE cores to land at 18 and is
still set up on 5 render slices RT units
get cut down as well they match the XE
cores and TVP is 150 wat the memory is
set up at 10 GB and that's still gddr6
but with 380 GB per second of bandwidth
the memory interface is a smaller 160
bits on the b570 here's a quick pricing
recap at the time of writing this and
ahead of launch we checked newon Amazon
for several gpus the Intel b580 GPU is
mostly out of stock at the actual MSRP
and being scalped at the time we're
writing this on New Egg get $340 and up
right now which is way too much to pay
for that card it's likely that when this
video launches the retailers will rest
stock with some B 580s that are closer
to normal but we can't review the future
although we can see it we normally scry
a pool of liquid metal we can see the
prices a couple days
out don't try that the RTX 460 is
currently around 295 to 320 bucks with
units regularly available at $300 and
the AMD RX 7600 is $250 as of writing
this making it the closest price
competition on a relatively modern
architecture is more directly
competitive with the b580 by Price than
it is with the the cheaper b570 and of
that we have a lot of charts to get
through today so we have tests with
three CPUs on them the way this is set
up is we have the 9800 x2d platform the
12400 platform and the 5600x platform
the 5600x is configured such that the
all core frequency is locked to the same
frequency as the max single core boost
so what that does is it controls the
variable so that we don't have the CPU
bounce around and following a Precision
boost curve in a way that won't
necessarily be identical runto run we do
the same thing with the 9800 x3d we lock
it out of frequency and then the 12400
is in here as well that gives us an
Intel platform to look at from one of
Intel's best recent Generations that
didn't have massive problems and then uh
the typical sort of philosophy for
testing there's a lot of ways to do it
uh as long as you kind of explain it and
can defend the choices as a reviewer
then whatever it's fine the way we view
it is the objective is to isolate the
variable simply because having a lot of
variables makes it really complicated
really fast and you just got to pick you
try represent sort of one situation or
as many of them as possible and so we do
a high-end platform for GPU reviews
where the CPU is intended to not
bottleneck the GPU that is sort of the
traditional approach and then we also
for CPUs we do the opposite we have a
high on GPU with CPUs and all that's
intentional we've explained it over the
years uh but that's kind of the approach
to it and it's just to isolate variables
and eliminate unnecessary bottlenecks so
that we can try and bind the thing that
really matters uh the thing we're doing
here here is a little different we are
introducing the CPU as a potential
variable reducing the performance of the
CPU with the 5600x and the 12400 in
addition to the 9800 x2d and what that
does is there will be situations where
the CPU simply can't keep up with
feeding frames to the GPU uh because
it's got its own problems going on this
can get complicated depending on the
games being tested in the settings
because if you start bouncing off of a
CPU ceiling it can really screw up the
frame times and that might not be sort
of the fault of the GPU but as the end
user it all manifests the same way which
is just a terrible experience if it's
the wrong combination of things and so
that's something we're going to be
looking for today now the current Topic
at least as we've seen it sort of
discussed mostly in the comments is
where I've been paying attention to
what's the public understanding of this
right now is that Intel may be
disproportionately hurt by driver
overhead and that uh has been attached
to lower resolution it's been attached
to 1080p really uh based on what we've
seen so far what it should be attached
to is low GPU load but but 1080p is
often synonymous with that so it's an
important distinction we'll show you why
but that's a distinction to be made now
our testing is done with all the same
games and game settings we use for our
9800 xpd testing so we're using high or
Ultra type settings and basically
playing it like most people would where
you're trying to sort of get the most
out of your GPU max out the settings uh
but we've lowered the CPU quality to
those two mentioned and that means that
even 1080p for our testing approach will
often still be GPU bottlenecked
especially on these cards and um that's
just because the way we've set it up we
we try to force the bottleneck onto the
GPU but also represent a likely scenario
so anyway let's get into the numbers
we're focusing on how the GPU scale from
one CPU to the next rather than just the
GPU to GPU comparison differences this
chart is for Final Fantasy 14 at 1080p
will highlight all the b580 rows first
with a 9800 x2d the b580 and a 124 FPS
average with a 5600x and a fixed all
core frequency it was 122 with a 12400
it was 120 there is no substantial
change to the b580 performance across
these three CPUs with this test
configuration moving to the 4060 the
4060 on the 9800x 3D bench 5600x bench
and 12400 bench performed identically it
was about 112 to 114 FPS average on all
of them there's no substantial change to
Performance the RX 7600 saw a
performance drop on the i52400 but on
the other two systems it was about the
same the d570 we observed approximately
equivalent performance from the 12400
5600x and 9800x 3D as such the percent
difference between all these devices is
overall comparable in this test despite
which CPU is used across all tested
devices we did however observe a
reduction in 0.1% low performance as the
CPU was reduced to lower performance
levels for example the RX 7600 with the
9800 x3d at 84 FPS 0.1% versus with the
5600x at 62.1 this is expected here's
the 1440p test in this one we did not
observe a meaningful difference in b580
performance across all three CPUs the
same is true for the 4060 and the 7600
we're not able to detect any differences
Beyond slight variant across platforms
the b570 also does not scale differently
and scores almost identically on all
three the data consistency for average
FPS actually is remarkable there and
this means that the Unbound data later
will be sufficient for establishing
differences between averages as for the
lows we're seeing consistently reduced
lows on the lower end CPUs in this game
it's not always true it is here the
5600x and the 12400 both had worse 0.1%
lows than the 9800 x3d with b570 with
the RTX 460 we're seeing stable 0.1%
lows across all three devices with the
7700 XT we saw differing lows between
the 9800 x2d and the 12400 with the 7600
we saw stable lows across all three it
would appear that based on the b580 b570
and a770 data there may be an argument
in this specific game and with these
settings where there are worse lows on
lower end CPUs for Arc
disproportionately we'll need more games
to finish Final Fantasy though at 4K
everything's remarkably consistent this
mostly includes the lows as well
although there are exceptions like the
9800 x3d and the 5600x for the a770
broadly speaking all gpus are about the
same here across all configurations uh
in terms of their card against itself
measurements this is cyon at 1080p Ultra
we'll go through it fast the results do
not change CPU to CPU the only
differences are on the 46 where we see
worse lows on the lower-end CPUs and the
7700 XT where we see a change in 0.1%
lows the b580 and b570 do not exhibit a
change in fact realistically the CPU
change does not affect any of these
results with regard to how we do a
standard review they are the same from
our testing perspective this is GPU
bound so that's what you'd expect some
of the internet has lost the plot and
think that Arc bad 1080p but it's really
not that simple it depends on the GPU
load and the game Starfield is known to
be problematic for art we have that
discussion the Standalone chart for it
but we'll focus on the scaling only
within a given card here we did not
observe a difference in the relative
ranking of the b580 or the b570 versus
their competition in this test relative
percent scaling did not get worse with
lower nend CPUs at 1080p there is a
slight difference at the top end with
the 7700 XD and the 12400 as a potential
CPU bind comes into play the RTX 460 is
identical in average FPS performance
across all three CPUs however we
observed worse frame time pacing on the
5600x and the 12400 the RTX 460
ultimately they are the same level of
reduction from the 9800 x2d so the two
lower end CPUs are comparable to each
other the RX 7600 is identical in
average FPS performance and within
variance on all three again the 9800 x2d
has a slight advantage in frame time
pacing the b580 is identical on all
three for average FPS there's no
meaningful difference in frame time
pacing or 0.1% low performance note
though that the b580 has some
Troublesome lows in this game already
but they don't get worse for lower end
CPUs that may be because they are
already sort of uh just reduced from
Intel Arc drivers to begin with the b570
is the same and the results are within
variant for all three metrics this is
Resident Evil 4 at 1080p the 7700 XT
exhibits a slight stealing with the
12400 but is mostly comparable the b580
ran at 128 FPS average with the 9800 x2d
and 122 with the 5600x we didn't run
tests on this one for the 12400
configuration the b570 had all three
though the 9800 x2d has it at 110 FPS
average or 5% ahead of its 5600x
configuration for the b570 and 5.7%
ahead of its 12400 configuration the RTX
460 ran at 107.9 FPS average on the 9800
x3d and 106.5 on the 12400 the RTX 460
shows a top to bottom range of 1.3%
smaller than the observed difference on
the b570 this slightly reconstructs the
stack such that the b570 ends up
slightly tied or under the RTX 460
rather than ahead of it by 2.1% when you
look at the same CPU that they're paired
with however the reduction puts the 4060
on like for like Hardware maximally 2%
ahead so between the two realistically
they are about the same experientially
as for the 0.1% low performance The Arc
cards underperform compared to the RTX
460 on all CPUs this does not get
disproportionately worse on the 5600x or
the 12400 and instead scales with the
average this disadvantage and lows
exists on on the 9800 x2d standard CPU
and on the lower end ones next is balers
Gate 3 we only run this at 1440 and 4K
due to the low load in this test the
7700 XT found a hard bottleneck with the
i52400 this capped out at 79 FPS average
as opposed to the Unbound test at 133
this would be appropriate for a CPU
review but does not show GPU performance
the RTX 460 on the 12400 further
reinforces these limits although it
bounces off of them way harder with much
worse 0.1% lows as a result of the CPU
not the GPU the RTX 460 exhibits
identical average FPS with all three
configurations the lows are better on
the 9800 x2d as it allows the GPU to hit
frame pacing without external binds
which is expected Behavior the RX 7600
is restricted by the CPUs with the 5600x
and i52400 with both lower than the 9800
xpds result again this is normal and is
expected from ACB bind lows are hurt as
a result of the limited ceiling the b580
also experienced a performance reduction
with the 12400 but a much larger one
with the 5600 X so to do some quick math
the RX 7600 at 77.1 FPS average with the
12400 gains
11.1% by moving to the 9800 x3d the b580
with the 12400 at 63.7 FPS average gains
16.2% by moving to the 9800 X it's not
as big of a difference as we might
expect but it is larger than what we saw
with the 7600 the 5600x is a far
different story with a maximum uplift of
32% from the 5600 a unit to the 9800 X
at 74 FPS average this is not just the
CPU bind that may well be The Driver
overhead discussion the b570 shows
similar Behavior with scaling worse on
the 5600x than on the 12400 lows are not
disproportionately worse on any of them
for that one in other words the lows
follow the behavior relative to the
other devices also scaling with the CPU
this would possibly change our
recommendation for a 5600x user but not
for a 12400 user where the difference
there is only 3 FPS in the b570 at 4K
the 7700 XD is the same on both CPUs for
average FPS but worse in frame time pce
and on the 12400 this is expected
behavior when using a worse CPU the a770
has identical performance between the
9800 X2 and the 5600x the RTX 460 has
identical performance between all three
there's a 1.3 FPS average difference as
a result of not only run to run variance
between the three but also the frame
time pacing is much better on the 9800
x2d for the 4060 and that influences the
average results the RX 7600 has the same
average FPS on all three CPUs with
better frame time pacing on the 9800 x3d
the b570 is identical on all three CPUs
with better lows on the 9800 x2d all of
this is expected behavior for a GPU bind
black myth will be fast as well at 1080p
High which is our standardized test
platform there's no meaningful broad
difference in scaling the numbers do not
change in any meaningful way for our
testing the 7700 XD is the same on both
the 4060 is the same on all three the
7600 is the same on all three with the
exception of of reduced lows on the
12400 the b580 is the same on all three
and lows are within variance run to run
the b570 is the same on all three with
lows within the wider variant at the low
end and the a770 is the same on both
that we ran let's look at one more in
Dragon's Dogma 2 they are all the same
from CPU to CPU with a few notes the
7700 XT is roughly identical the 4060 is
mostly identical with the 12400
potentially showing marginally worse
performance the RX 7600 is the same
across all three with slightly worse
0.1% lows on some of them the B 580 is
the same across all three with worse
0.1% lows specifically on the 5600 a the
b570 is the same across all three in all
three metrics the a770 is the same in
all three metrics so let's quickly talk
results first in most scenarios for our
testing there's no meaningful impact
that does not mean there is never impact
there can be the key here is in our
testing and the biggest situation we saw
was with the 5600x with bers Gate 3 I
think it was at 1440p where we saw a
sort of a a stair step it was 5600x
12400 9800x 3D it starts to look like a
CPU review does where in a CPU review
you're going to see scaling with CPUs in
this scenario though the
5600x uh was sort of disproportionately
low and that was especially true on the
b580 we looked at the b570 in some
situations where the 12400 and the 9800
X were much closer to each other to the
extent that between the two there is
functionally no meaningful difference so
one of them was like three FPS
difference who cares it's it's kind of
all the same conclusion one way or the
other so in that scenario the only thing
that would really change for us is the
recommendation for a 5600 x user for
that scenario might change by and large
though there's not a huge swing here uh
with the exception of some 0.1% low
numbers Shuffle around but it's not
always just on battle mage it just
depends on the game and the card so uh
the short version of it is this this
doesn't affect our review here because
our approach is already built in a way
to heavily load the GPU and so we we
want to make that clear that there is no
data with our testing to support that
our conclusions would be meaningfully
different in a wide sweeping way if we
tested it with the lowend CPUs or the
high-end CPUs but in this video you get
both uh and so you can kind of make that
decision yourself if you want but the
numbers are functionally identical in
most situations so what it does do is
Cap the ceiling and you can see that uh
now again there let's not to say there's
not driver overhead and we are aware
that at this point multiple Outlets have
shown situations where you can get it
one of the trends I've noticed between
them is that a lot of the times it's on
really high frame rates so like 200 FPS
plus you'll start to see it emerge more
uh and then it also seems to Trend with
some of the Esports type games which we
don't currently really test and so maybe
that's a a next content piece for us but
for purposes of the review you know what
matters to us is okay well we've got a
review Suite let's test this current
discussion with hour review suite and
see if it needs to change uh and danc as
well but not really but even if you
cared then there's the numbers for you
so anyway we may revisit this with um
with uh some of those super high FPS
titles Esports titles whatever in a
separate video but for now uh you've got
the the information to work with so if
you want to see scenarios where some of
that driver overhead that's being
discussed might emerge we'd encourage
you to check out other reviews there are
plenty of them out there where they're
probably going to be looking into it
some people will have examples and and
others won't just depends on what you
test okay let's get into the rest of the
charts we're going to go through it
standard now and that includes
rasterization and R tracing because we
spent so much time on this thing up
front uh we won't have uh as much length
on the efficiency but there is
efficiency at the end here's the rest
Final Fantasy 14 at 4K is up first for
the Unbound benchmarks on the 9800x 3D
in this one the b570 ran at about 41 FPS
average establishing a 16% Advantage for
the b580 at 47 FPS average against a 14%
price Bump by MSRP so this is pretty
close to linear the b570 roughly ties
the a770 and average FPS at 1% low with
0.1% lows close enough it also
outperforms the RTX 460 by 11% the 3060
by 23% and the a580 by the same the RX
7600 card landed at around 32 FPS
average giving the b570 a notable lead
especially at the price they're also
substantial improvements on the RX 6600
which was the previous leader in this
priz class though it eventually sold for
cheaper for some references to older
cards we also have the GTX 1070 1060 and
1650 present you can pause for those at
1440p the b570 ran at 75 FPS average
against the b580 is 86 FPS average which
puts the b580 about 15% ahead of the
b570 the lead was marginally higher at
4K the b570 now sits between the a770
and a750 so the a770 has slightly
repositioned itself as resolution came
down the RTX 460 also gets closer to the
b570 now at 72 FPS average nearing
equivalence despite a larger Gap
previously this is the same behavior we
saw in the b580 review the higher the
resolution goes generally speaking the
more of an advantage battle mage can
develop over some of its peers in the
class the leader of the RX 7600 is 14%
here with the RX 6600 XT and 360 below
it some older reference anchors include
again the 2060 the 1070 The 1060 and the
1650 you can pause for those and frame
time pacing on the b570 is good overall
performing similarly to 4060 for frame
to frame interval at 1080p the b570
loses its advantage against the RX 7600
and RTX 460 the b580 maintains a lead
over these two cards with its 124 FPS
average although its frame time pacing
indicated by the 0.1% lows is worse than
what we're seeing on the RTX 460 and RX
7600 we dove into this in the b580
review overall battle mage and the b570
remain a large improvement over
Alchemist especially at the price
however we still see that reduction
uction and relative performance as
resolution decreases even with an
Unbound configuration at 1440p and
higher battle mage when Unbound seems to
be more competitive than it is at 1080p
Starfield is next Intel had a lot of
problems with Starfield when the game
launched namely the problem was it
didn't work but it does now sort of
despite working Nvidia and AMD retain an
advantage with the RTX 460 and the RX
7600 cards the b580 is 41 FPS average at
these settings leads the B5 70 is 36 FPS
by 12% the RX 7600 leads by 177% with
the RTX 460 leading by a staggering 31%
this is an example of one of the games
where battle mage is disadvantaged even
when Unbound even at 1440p at 1080p the
b570 GPU ran at 47 FPS average placing
it between the a770 of last gen and the
RC 6600 XT against Alchemist it's clear
that battle mage is a huge Improvement
when considering the configuration size
of the a770 GPU again against the b570
GPU against itself Intel has definitely
improved in huge ways against
competition the RTX 460 and RX 7600 both
hold advantages at both the resolution
and with the game the b580 ends up 10%
ahead of the b570 in this test so its
value isn't always linear Resident Evil
4 at 4K was one of the b580 strongest
titles in this test the b580 marginally
outperformed the 4060 TI and averages
with the 0.1% lows close enough to be
compar able given wider margins the b580
at 46 FPS average leads the b570 is 40
FPS average by about 16% aligning with
some of the other 4K results the b570
ends up outperforming the RX 7600 by 7%
and the RTX 460 by 14% which is an
incredible lead for the b570 when fully
GPU bound considering the RTX 460s price
this is again a big Improvement for
Intel the Improvement on the a580 is
also noteworthy with similar gains lows
on the b570 are not meaning meaningfully
different from those on the RX 7600 the
6600 XD or the RTX 46d so frame pacing
is similar on those at 1440p the b580 is
still spaced about 16% over the b570 the
b570 is lead over the RX 7600 has
reduced and they are now mostly
equivalent with the b570 experiencing
less consistent lows this is something
we showed and talked about in the b580
review so if you'd like to learn more
about why it hits that ceiling you can
watch that one the RTX 460 also climbs
relative to the b570 with its 70 FPS
average result reducing the b570 is
advantage to just 6% this is while the
RTX 460 maintains slightly better 0.1%
low results for a better average frame
to frame interval the b570 is still
overall better here but as we continue
to reduce resolution that changes this
is 1080p with these settings the b570 is
now roughly tied with the 7600 the RTX
460 is encroaching on the b570 which has
had its lead when GPU bound cut to just
2% that's still impressive for the price
and for the the new age of Intel's new
architecture if we imagine the b570 line
item were some hypothetical new Nvidia
card at the same price and performance
here $220 this would be an amazing move
in the right direction for NVIDIA the
fact that it's Intel and Intel is still
proving itself and working through some
of those early teething pains uh is
really the only hesitation that remains
they have however reduced that concerned
generationally so far even still the b57
is frame time pacing is inconsistent it
bounces around in this title runto run
with run to- run variants higher than
we'd see on AMD or Nvidia devices this
remains a challenge in some specific
games but not all it's overall
acceptable but not as consistent as its
peers as for the b580 its lead over the
b570 is about 18 FPS or 16.4% next up is
balers Gate 3 which remains one of the
best titles launched in the last couple
years at 4K the b570 ran at 40 FPS
average with our ultra settings this has
it just below the 3060 and above the
a580 RX 6600 and RTX 2060 the b580 is
44.8 FPS average result leads the b570
by 133% with both exhibiting limited
scaling and the 0.1% lows indicating
frame-to-frame consistency issues as
compared to Nvidia neighbors 1440p has
the b570 at 67 FPS average between the
a750 and the a580 the generational
uplift isn't nearly as impressive here
as in some of the other games the b580
is about 11% better than the b570 here
uh so that's not as high elsewhere
either and the RTX 460s 80 FPS average
puts it 20% ahead in average FPS plus a
significant uplift in 0.1% lows to
represent smoother frame time pacing the
RX 7600 outperforms both the 4060 and
the b570 including in the lows let's
move to cyberpunk Phantom Liberty at
1440p in this test the b570 ran at 46
FPS average with the b580 at 54 FPS
average the b580 is lead is about 16%
which is consistent with other high load
scenarios in fact the b580 bordered on
the RTX 470 in this test which we didn't
see happen elsewhere but which has
consistently happened in this game its
lows aren't nearly as good as what the
RTX 470 offers at 50 FPS 0.1% to 31 but
this was still a good showing in
averages for battle mage if they were to
even out the lows then that average
might come down a little bit depending
on where they're spiking the b570
reinforces this it functionally ties an
average with the 6700 XT this is an
impressive fee for both it's the memory
bandwidth we think benefiting the cards
tier unfortunately the low pacing just
isn't as good on the b570 as its
neighboring devices including the larger
config a series like the a750 the b570
leads the 460 x 18% here in a staggering
flip favoring battle mage for averages
again with the caveat being the lows are
better on Nvidia at 1080p the b570 ran
at 71 FPS average with b580 sustaining a
133% uplift in average frame rate battle
mage still has worse lows than neor
Neighbors at this resolution the 4060
begins to encroach on the b570 and
functionally ties it in average frame
rate while offering substantially
improved frame pacing Behavior the RX
7600 is about the same roughly tied with
the 4060 and overall a better experience
than the b570 black myth hon is next
tested at 1080p High first with these
settings the b570 maintains about 40 FPS
average with lows around or below 30 FPS
average this has the RX 6600 XT and RTX
360 both above the B5 70 with the b570
above the 6600 non XT and the RTX 2060
the b580 is 46 FPS average gives it a
lead of 15% over the b570 with the 7600
16% ahead and the RTX 460 at 54 FPS
average here ahead of the b570 by 36%
it's a huge lead for the 4060 at 1440p
the b570 is reduced to 30 FPS average
this gives the 4060 a 22% lead with the
b580 is 35 FPS average about 15% ahead
so the b570 did gain on the 4060 the
4060 however still maintains a huge lead
Dragon Dogma 2 is up next first at 1440p
Max without RT in this test the b580
sticks to a 15% lead over the b570 so
that's consistent the RTX 460 leads the
b580 and the b570 alike with the RX 7600
about tied with the RTX 460 and within
run- to run variants the b570 is not
particularly strong here it's about the
same as the 360 and it outperforms the
6600 nxd the price is noteworthy
although the b580 is overall more
competitive in raw performance in the
least lows are comparable in this test
to non- inel Parts at 1080p performance
Falls overall as compared to competition
this is consistent with other tests the
Gap from the b570 to the b580 remains
15% with the 4060 now leading the b570
by 30% and the b580 by 7% amds RX 7600
holds a similar lead d light 2 is up now
at 1440p the b570 ran at 53 f average in
what's one of the strongest relative
showings Unbound for this card this has
it ahead of the 4060 by 8% lows are also
better which is important for Arc uh the
lead over the 7600 is 133% as for the
b580 Intel's $250 Baseline model is
about 18.6% ahead of the b570 here at
1080p the b580 maintained an 18.7%
advantage at 87 fps to 73 FPS average
over the b570 the RTX 460 lands between
the two and is closer to the b57
Intel has marginally better 0.1% low
averages here the RX 7600 is roughly
tied with the b570 in this test we're
moving on to rate tracing now tested
with the Unbound configuration we'll
keep this as focused as possible these
tests are not comparable to the
rasterization performance especially as
some settings such as upscaling may
change in Resident Evil 4 at 4K with rt
and FSR the b570 ran at 43 FPS average
and with lows overall acceptable for its
average that has it ahead of the RTX 460
and a strong showing for Intel the B5
580 leads the b570 by 16% which puts it
functionally identical in performance to
the RTX 460 TI at 1440p the b570 ran at
66 FPS average and tied with the RX 7600
in just about every metric considering
the b570 is price Advantage at the time
of writing that's a competitive spot to
be in for Intel the RTX 460 leads the
b570 by 8% flipping from what we saw at
the higher resolution and consistent
with knowledge that Arc
disproportionately scales better that is
at higher resolution the b580 is 15%
ahead of the b570 here at 1080p the b570
ran at 81 FPS average the RX 7600 now
slightly outperforms it realistically
these are the same perceived performance
but lower resolution performance scaling
remains stronger on Nvidia and AMD the
RTX 460 is now up at 95 FPS average a
lead over the b570 of 177% of course
there's a price difference too the b580
is about tied with the RTX 460 dlight 2
is up with rt now at 1080p the b570 ran
at 55 FPS average and held portional
lows which is what we want these results
have it close enough to the RTX 460 that
they're experientially the same the RTX
460 has a lead of 5% over the b570 with
the b580 leading both at its 65 FPS
average the b580 is average frame rate
is 18% higher than the b570 in a notable
distinction the RX 7600 lands below all
of these closer to the RTX 360 and Below
even the a580 Intel's Arc has overall
strong RT in this title Dragon's Dogma 2
with rt is not that way though at 1080p
the b570 ran at 39 FPS average
unfortunately for Intel this is one of
its worst relative results rate tracing
in this game is hard for the Intel cards
they don't maintain the scaling from
elsewhere when tested against the 7600
or the RTX 460 here at 1440p the b570
holds a 31 FPS average the b580 a 36 FPS
average and the 7600 and 460 both just
under 40 FPS average again Intel is
disproportionately disfavored in this
test set cyberpunk with rt Medium as
next battle mage remains super
competitive here with the b570
Performing better than the RTX 460 the
average frame rate is about the same but
the RTX 460 suffers from wildly
inconsistent frame times in this test we
showed that in the b580 review with the
frame time plot where the 460 was spiky
as a result of its vram limitation the
b580 keeps its 16% lead over the b570 in
this test with both outdoing the 4060
the RTX 4060 TI even struggles in this
one also suffering from inconsistent run
to- run variance and low performance for
0.1% AMD has problems of its own mostly
just that it's unable to compete in this
test the RX 7600 is down under 30 FPS
average with these settings at this
price point battle mage is actually the
best in this specific test and setup
black myth who call is up next with rt
this is one of our experimental charts
this designation is reserved for charts
where we're still evaluating the
methodology and the accuracy and so you
shouldn't assign as much weight to these
since we're still leaving open the
possibility of some sort of test
limitation or issue
as it stands now the b570 lands between
the a750 and the a580 with rt the b580
is about the same as the RX 7800 XT with
the b570 outperforming the RX 7600 so
both are competitive with AMD Nvidia is
up in orbit though with this game the
RTX 460 is way up at 52 FPS average in
this test with these settings efficiency
testing is up next this is also part of
our suite of experimental tests meaning
that we're still developing methods and
that there's more room than for possible
error or future revisions this testing
is done with an Elmer Labs pmd2 that's
been calibrated personally by Elmer on
our request testing includes both pcie
slot and pcie cable power consumption
and it excludes all other power
including the CPU in idle testing Intel
Arc remains power hungry as compared to
its competition with our test platform
this is as configured for benchmarking
and has the b570 pulling about 30 Watts
idle the b580 was around 35 Watts so
this is overall High balers Gate 3 at
1440p shows FPS per watt meaning that
higher frame rate and lower power will
create the most efficient result higher
is better the most efficient device here
so far is the 4060 TI of those tested
the b580 was in the middle of the pack
at 0.52 FPS per watt that had it between
the 6600 series The b570 is more
efficient than the b580 at 0.55 FPS per
watt and below the RX 7800 XT Final
Fantasy 14 at 1440p is an okay showing
for b570 at 0.54 FPS per watt it's near
the RTX 460 and better than the b580
this is an okay spot to be in for Intel
at 1080p the b570 produces 0.81 FPS per
watt and sits again below the RTX 46d
and above the b580 and 7800 XT against
AMD Intel is looking good but Nvidia
maintains its Advantage here in black
myth at 1080p the b570 sits between the
4060 and the b580 again performance is
acceptable overall and far improved from
the a series like the a580 or A7 7
cyberp Punk is the last one this one's a
pretty good showing for Intel the b570
isn't tied with the RTX 460 but it's
getting a lot closer the 0.28 FPS per
watt result is far improved over the
7800 XT and puts it in fourth of the
devices tested so far for efficiency
note that the 490 looks a lot less
efficient here than it is not
particularly efficient but because it's
becoming Bound by other components at
this resolution all right that's it for
this one so you got all the charts you
can make the decision some quick
highlights here a lot of this is the
same general feeling as the v580 in the
sense that Intel has definitely improved
that is demonstrable it's very clear and
over Alchemist they have certainly
picked up from where they were so b580
and the b570 are often outperforming the
a750 or the a770 which are larger
configs especially the a770 and so
that's a good place for Intel to be
against itself now against competition
uh they do trade back and forth a lot so
there's some games where the b570 is
similar to or even even a little bit
exceeding the the RTX 4060 there's other
situations where it's the opposite uh
the trend that persists is that the
higher the resolution is regardless of
this driver overhead discussion this has
been true since day one since we posted
our review the b580 the higher the
resolution is typically the more the
battle mage series cards will either
gain on their competition or pull away
from them depending on where they
started and so you could look at the
other way too you could say as you
approach lower resolutions like 1080p
then they get closer together and a lot
of times they flip so in some of these
charts you'll see the 4060 flip with the
b580 or something at 1080P and maybe
1440p or they're equal there and then
the b580 might gain a lead at 4K and
that sort of remains true with the b570
with the exception that it is a little
bit of a weaker device at least when not
overclocked and as a result the uh the
460 is uh more distant from it than you
would see the b580 so now like in the
b580 review one of the big things is we
did not have any spectacular failures
and crashes this time so the b580 we had
one that I can remember mentioning there
might be more in there but um the one I
remember was in cyberpunk with I think
it was specifically ultra settings for
the b580 review we didn't have that this
time with this one so that might have
gotten patched in some of the driver
updates or something maybe we just got
lucky uh but compared to Alchemist it's
certainly far improved Nvidia still sort
of seen as maybe the default driver set
in that it is genuinely very reliable I
we rarely have problems with nidus
drivers at this point uh it is built on
like over a decade of updates decades I
guess at this point and you see that in
the driver performance and the stability
but Intel's improving for sure as for
value and purchasing the b580 remains
actually a very competitive value
there's an asteris cure we'll come back
to the b570 is much the same um on
average the b580 and our results tends
to be about 15 to 16% better than the
b570 at the upper end of that we'll see
18.7 19% somewhere in there for the b580
advantage over the b570 at the lower end
we'll see like 10% or so uh barring some
kind of other major bind happening I
think one might have been as low as 6%
in a certain situation uh so that's
about the difference that difference
more or less aligns with the price
difference at 250 versus $220 or so uh
and then if these get scalped again
don't don't spend more than seems
reasonable on it I 300 plus for any of
these cards really is too much this is
too much so that's it for this one the
driver overhead things super interesting
it's an important part of the discussion
uh once again not to sort of say it too
much but in our testing it's just not
emerging the way we do it however the
things we want to do next as a
standalone piece possibly uh will be a
true CPU bind so that's either we go
even lower end on the CPU with the same
settings or what's more likely is we run
our CP review Suite settings on it which
is going to be mostly medium settings uh
we pull it all the way down to low or
something for an unlikely scenario but
one that would maybe force the problem
to emerge just like isolating variables
elsewhere in hardware and uh and then we
can look at okay what are the situations
where maybe this is a problem and how
much does it emerge but if they're
moving in Step though you have to look
at is the scaling still the same uh and
if it is then the conclusions are the
same but the sort of uh situation that
we're seeing in some of these games like
some of the Esports titles is that it
might not be in Step where Nvidia is
favored in some of those so we'll
explore that it'll be a standalone um as
of right now what I can say is with the
three CPUs we tested with the game
settings we use with the games we use
the conclusions are pretty much aligned
in all those situations except for
balers Gate 3 with the 5600x uh and then
some of those frame time discussions
that we had throughout this video If you
really care about the frame time
consistency then then just you'll have
to watch through it or click through the
charts or something so or watch the b58
with the frame time section that's it
thanks for watching uh subscribe for
more check back we have a lot more
coming up we're going to do some more of
the uh it's been fun it's been fun doing
the bottleneck type testing so we'll do
some more with that now that we've got a
bench up and running for it and then of
course the 50 Series should be coming up
kind of soon for reviews so we'll have
those as well on the high end and you
can go to store. Gamers access.net to
help us out directly like by buying some
of our shirts our mod mats for PC
Building or our dice kits and we'll see
you all next time